monsieur lancelot pas vous-mêmes Pirlo Rose
le président des États-Unis d'
Amérique je n'ai aucune idée de ce que cela signifie
je suis Larry c'est mon fils Nick ne vous
me rappelez pas un homme que j'ai connu une fois à
Camelot vraiment l'un des chevaliers  de la
table ronde
Eric Eric un imbécile c'était l'imbécile le plus drôle que
j'aie jamais rencontré
il était si bon tu as ce qu'il avait le
don je craignais que tu puisses être un imbécile eh bien je
ne sais pas ça oh allez
bien sûr tu pourrais nous  offrez-vous un de ces
chapeaux avec de drôles de petites
clochettes pendantes le cadeau qu'il fait ce qui
ressemble à ne ressemble à rien est-ce une
minuscule petite unité inexpressive